all right happening this week shark days
returns to the Golden Nugget yeah feed
the sharks take some selfies and learn
about the massive creatures Candace
Charles's life at but not in the Shark
Tank at the Golden Nugget with a preview
of Candace oh she's got some food right
there oh Candice be careful
oh you know I'm ready good morning into
the morning folks yes it is feeding time
for these little guys just getting a nut
to get I have someone here with me I can
tell you when you can do it and when you
can see this all happen let the Cornell
Thank you so much for joining us today
first of all I'll start by telling you
what's on the menu here what do these
guys eat hi Candace so these are a
couple only a few of the items that we
feed our sharks as you can see there's a
variety of things on here
um some of our sharks are very large 200
pounds so they would kind of eat more of
the Bluefish and Bonitas and mackerels
some of our smaller guys are going to
eat more of the inverts we've got some
crabs here squid Wings clams
um and some trips so a variety for
everyone we also make sure that we put
vitamins in all of our food for the
animals so these we all need vitamins
and these are what are actually specific
vitamins for sharks and then also some
thiamine paste which really helps the
animals especially since they eat some
Frozen flawed food okay well it looks
delicious tell us about what people can
expect from Shark days it's a whole week
of fun right yeah so there's a whole
week dedicated to sharks
um so we've got a couple of great things
going on our guests can come to the
swimming pool and we'll have a scavenger
hunt going on so there'll be some
pictures posted around the pool so
everybody can kind of spend some time
looking for certain items some of them
are super small so you got to look close
um also we're going to be doing our
shark feeds that people can watch from
down below
um so our first feed will be on
Wednesday at 10 A.M and then on Friday
at 1 45. so as long as you're down below
you should be able to get a pretty good
show of our sharks doing our fish eating
right that's where all the acts are the
lips so thank you we appreciate it it
sounds like it's going to be a fantastic
week coming up we're getting up close
and personal with these guys a little
nervous but it's gonna be okay you guys
won't want to miss this little question
find out more details about shark dick
we can talk tomorrow on the
westbagesnow.com we're now live from the
strike today at the golden
[Laughter]
be careful